it's a tale as old as time Bell is
another Disney princess who doesn't have
a mother but what really happened to
Belle's mom stay tuned to find out let's
check out what really happened to
Belle's mother in Beauty and the Beast
the original story okay we're throwing
it way back at first to figure out what
happened to Belle's mom
the original story looked a lot
different from the Disney version Belle
was the youngest daughter of a merchant
she had three brothers and two sisters
they were rich but their father lost his
fortune Belle or Beauty was not just
beautiful she was also the kindest of
her siblings they were all snobs the
story was originally intended to teach
the virtues of goodness and humility but
there is something missing from the
original story beauty's mom that's right
even in the old story
there was no mom it makes sense that
Disney would pick up this fairy tale to
turn into a movie it sure seems like
Disney has something against mothers so
many princesses and other Disney
characters do not have moms Snow White
Cinderella and Ariel are all motherless
princesses that came before Belle maybe
it's not just Disney what D fairy tales
have against living mothers anyway the
animated movie in 1991 Belle joined the
ranks of the Disney Princesses Beauty
and the Beast was a huge hit and remains
one of the most popular Disney movies
ever and it should it's a great movie
with amazing songs and Belle is the
first princess who wants more than just
a love story she is smart and brave she
loves to read and she is able to bring
out the good in the beast when the movie
begins Belle laments living in your poor
provincial life she hates that she lives
in a boring small town all the people do
the same thing every day no one
understands her love of reading or her
father's inventing they are the town
outcasts only one person wants anything
to do with Belle and that's Gaston soon
Issaquah I don't know what that means
he's a gross guy who won't take no for
an answer but he only wants to marry her
because she's pretty he doesn't
appreciate her mind her father goes to
try and sell his latest invention he
gets lost in the woods and attacked by
wolves he runs and finds a dark castle
that looks abandoned but the castle is
enchanted all the household staff has
the
turned into objects like Lumiere the
candelabra and mrs. pots the teapots the
master of the castle is Prince Adam he
was cursed for being unkind by an
enchantress she turned him into a beast
he must find true love by the time the
last petal falls on an enchanted rose
he takes Belle's father prisoner so he
won't tell anyone about the castle Belle
goes after him she offers herself as
prisoner so her father who is old and
ill will survive Belle isn't afraid to
call the beast out on his rude manners
and bad attitude
the household objects who want the two
to fall in love before they are doomed
to turn into real objects forever slowly
the Beast begins to respect Belle she
starts to see that he's got a good sign
they fall in love
defeat Gaston and live happily ever
after the animated movie doesn't mention
Belle's mom at all
viewers are left wondering what happened
to her a Broadway musical was made based
on the movie it's almost exactly the
same and it has all the same songs but
in the stage version dolls mom is
mentioned her father says that Belle is
her mother's daughter because of this
she is class and is the creme de la
creme but what does that mean who is
Belle's mother
there are several fan theories about who
Belle's mother is let's check out a few
of these the first suggests that Belle's
mother was a member of French nobility
this makes sense with what her father
says in the stage musical if Bella's
class like her mother that likely means
that she is a member of the higher class
there were major differences in classes
during this time period in France the
nobility had a lot of options that
regular people didn't have they were
almost completely separate from society
this would also explain how Maurice and
Belle aren't totally poor their villages
poor that they owned a little land and
have animals they have a nice cottage
but the movie implies that Maurice is
not a successful inventor if they were
formerly part of the noble class they
would have money there is also another
fan theory about who Belle's mom is and
this one will blow your mind on reddit
user a versa goes into a lot of detail
about French royalty and rose symbolism
the user bases most of this theory off
of a portrait that hangs in Belle's
cottage at Disneyworld
we can't find a lot of evidence about
this painting but if the reddit user is
right this theory is crazy
this
theory suggests that Belle's mother is
none other than the Enchantress that's
right she might be the very same person
who cursed Prince Adam and his castle
and this all comes down to one very
important symbol the Rose this painting
of Belle and her mother shows Belle's
mother wearing a rose dress this may
indicate that those mother was a member
of the French noble house of Grenoble
the other side of the painting has
French lilies which are a symbol of
royalty now think back to the beginning
of the animated movie The Enchantress
shows up disguised as an ugly old lady
she offers the prints of Rose in return
for a place to stay he turns her away
and she turns into a beautiful
enchantress she then uses the rose to
mark the princes curse she's obviously a
shapeshifter
so the fact that Belle's mom had brown
hair isn't that big of a deal in this
theory what do you think is Belle's
mother The Enchantress it would
certainly explain why maurice liked her
so much in the live-action movie let us
know what you think in the comments
section can you read this there's no
pictures well some people use their
imagination what happened to Belle's
mother in 2017 Disney released a live
action version of Beauty and the Beast
it starred Emma Watson dan Stephens and
Luke Evans it was fantastic it stayed
true to the original in a lot of ways
but there were some major changes one
major change was that Marius Belle's
father made music boxes the inventor was
actually Belle we see her trying to
invent a laundry machine the updated
movie also explains some things in the
original movie we often wondered how no
one in the village knew there was a
magical castle nearby but the
live-action movie explains that
forgetting the castle and the royalty
was part of the curse that makes sense
we know that Belle's mother has passed
away and her father is still very sad
about it for some reason he moved to
Belle to the country for her safety but
Belle doesn't really know what that
means
then the Beast uses his magical book to
take her to her childhood home we find
out that they lived in Paris they were a
happy family in a small apartment
the Belle's mother got sick with the
plague the movie shows a plague mask
that was warned to keep doctors from
getting sick then we find out that
Belle's mother begs Maurice to take
Belle away she did not want her daughter
to
got the plague the plague was way less
common in the country villages at that
time
Maurice fled with Belle and the last
moments of her mother's life were spent
alone
so did Belle's mother really meet her
end by the play or is there some other
explanation let's take a look at another
Disney franchise the TV show once upon a
time is made by Disney it features a lot
of Disney characters in this show
Belle's mother is mentioned her name is
Colette and it is said that she lost her
life in the ogre Wars
we know that in Once Upon a Time all the
fairy tales are true in an alternate
world there is another possibility about
her mother's untimely end and this one
is based on history it is not a Disney
friendly possibility at all we know that
Beauty and the Beast is supposed to take
place in the late 18th century France
this was not a good time to be a member
of the nobility people generally thought
that Nobles behaved like spoiled Prince
Adam and there was a very violent
revolution many Nobles lost their lives
at the hands of commoners if Belle's
mother really was nobility her whole
family was in danger Maryse and Belle
could have fled to avoid the violent
mobs what do you think did Belle's
mother have the plague like the
live-action movie says or did she lose
her life in a war against augurs like
once upon a time has said there's always
the possibility that she had a more
historically accurate end maybe you have
another theory let us know in the
comments The Lost Prince all this talk
of French nobility leads us into another
theory who is Prince Adam up until 1792
the French royal family lived in the
Palace of Versailles this is not where
Prince Adam lives it is possible that he
is a son of the king and a woman who was
not the queen louis xiv had a secret
wife who was of a lower status in the
late 1700s louis xvi was king he was
married to Marie Antoinette these Royals
were run out of Versailles they were
imprisoned and lost their heads oh no
what a terrible way to go their son
Louis the 17th was just a child he
stayed in prison until he was 10 when he
passed away there has been a rumor for a
long time that there is a lost Prince of
France some people believe that Louis
the 17th was actually rescued from
prison and lived
his life under a different identity wait
a second there might be a French prince
from the right time period with a new
identity he doesn't have parents and was
really young when they were lost that
sure sounds like a lot like Prince Adam
don't you think a mysterious young
prince with no family and his parents
definitely had a reputation for being
mean to poor people Prince Adam probably
learned that behavior from his family do
you think Prince Adam might actually be
the lost Prince that's crazy
Maurice the inventor if bhau's mother
really was a member of the ruling class
how did she meet an eccentric inventor
well inventors weren't that weird
amongst the royalty in France automatons
were mechanical inventions that were
made to look like living things rich
people in France thought these were so
cool and let's be honest the kind of are
they were like early robots but they
couldn't think like a computer can
Maurice could have been an inventor for
the royalty if Belle's mother was
nobility they could have met at court
that's a pretty cool theory in the
live-action movie he makes music boxes
but those have a lot of the same
mechanisms that early automat instead
Maurice doesn't seem all that crazy
anymore there are a ton of fan theories
out there about Beauty and the Beast a
lot of them are full of history since
the story takes place at a really
interesting historical time of course
maybe all the fairy tales exists in
another world and Belle's mother did
fight augurs maybe the prince is not
based on any real person we'll never
know for sure but we still love Belle
and all the characters from her story
what do you think about all these
theories which version of the story do
you think is the most accurate sound off
with your own fan theories in the
comments section below and that's it for
what really happened to Belle's mother
in BD and the beast give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]